[Musique]
en famille la maman des enfants les
parents une tatie racisme mamie
acariâtre c'est parfait pas de la dal
farra une bûche aux marrons une bus on
essaie mais vu ce nom là tête
j'avais que c'était une ordure intox
intox on invoque cette news je suis
qu'il existe qui t'a dit il n'existait
pas c'est une intox parce que le père
noël existe il est dans le coeur de
chacun de nous
[Musique]
quels objets reçus c'est en fait à noël
j'ai pas eu de cadeau y avait des
cadeaux pour tout le monde nous attend
et moi j'avais mal travaillé j'avais pas
de cadeau ça va vraiment traumatisé et
des boutons de manchettes un trombone ne
met pas de boutons de manchette
rattacher les folies alala des boules de
bain j'ai déjà eu tellement mais mon
chéri m'a pas respecté il m'en faire une
patrie depuis tu es foutu danger
et
offrir un cadeau je crois il a tout le
mec mon amour inconsidéré club ce qui me
touche
un coup droit je lui fais une poterie
qu'avec même je vais chanter deux
chansons il faut lui offrir un cadeau
fait à flaine jeta newman ou mayenne
non mais après tu vas lui dire parce que
j'ai déjà le cadeau c'est trop beau
c'est romain disent quelque chose qui
brille autant maya a maille à aa
aubin le père noël est une ordure
heffermehl est une ordure et jean victor
hugo est facile à moi j'ai raté l'avion
maman j'ai raté l'avion love actually le
sapin a les boules
j'aime pas noël j'en ai pas de souligner
la campagne chez mes grands-parents il
s'est mis à neiger mais avril à c'était
était tout blanc et c'était absolument
un spectacle magnifique
quand j'ai vu ma grand-mère déguisé en
père noël dans le jardin je rêvais je
rêvais d'avoir un walkman et j'ai eu un
walkman et en plus j'avais eu le best of
de dorothée c'était mon meilleur ami
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
denise crise lui a donné deux pas de
baisse à domenech mais oui comme tout
hollywood conclut ce massif ue
c'est ça
[Musique]